piatti politique forte va-t-il renverser
la table il ya une hypothèse qui a
circulé
elle est reprise dans un papier de
karmous le rédacteur en chef politique
du figaro magazine papier qui a fait pas
mal de bruit depuis hier et qui explique
que emmanuel macron 7 à échanger avec
des grands donateurs c'est à dire ces
gens généreux qui ont contribué au
financement de sa campagne de 2017
ça se passait par téléconférence puisque
les donateurs en question habite londres
et le président d'après nos informations
leur aurait dit que il y avait une
hypothèse possible c'était qu'il
démissionne pour se représenter dans la
foulée alors depuis l'elysée a démenti
notre information
mais pour notre part nous la maintenons
est ce que ce serait une bonne idée ou
pas en tout cas ça provoquait beaucoup
de commentaires chez vous chers
internautes plusieurs centaines de
commentaires à l'article de carl meeus
en voici un celui de mac pro qui nous
dit président est a minima face à une
opinion morcelé ou bien rassembler sur
pour sur son nouveau projet par une
réélection
la seconde éventualité est risqué mais
elle correspond mieux à maquereau si ça
devait être une sortie elle ne serait
pas sans panache et il est probable
qu'on le regrettera
en tout cas ce qui est certain un cheikh
match pose c'est que dans l'esprit du
président de la république s'il devait
démissionner ce serait pour se
représenter dans la foulée et comme
selon lui il n'y a personne de crédible
face à lui il serait réélu jean daniel
lévy qu'est ce que vous pensez
si vous étiez le conseiller du président
de la république que lui conseilleriez
vous de faire ou de dire dimanche soir à
demain peut-être déjà en fait d'arriver
a effectivement avec une calculette
quelques bonnes nouvelles et puis
peut-être une forme d'empathie avec les
françaises et les français tout en
montrant la maîtrise de l'ensemble du
dispositif
une des critiques a été effectuée à
l'égard d' emmanuel macron à l'égard de
l'exécutif a été le sentiment qu'il soit
arrivé souvent avec une flotte de trains
de retard
un train de retard sur les tests un
train de retard sur les masques un train
de retard sur le confinement un train de
retard sur l'organisation du premier
tour des élections municipales et que le
gouvernement a plutôt été à chaque fois
n'ont pas véritablement maîtrisés en
avance sur le sujet mais plus en
réaction à des événements qui étaient
extérieurs est ce qu'on a pu voir
jusqu'à présent en dehors de cette crise
du coc vider ses cuves lorsque emmanuel
macron était apprécié de la part des
françaises et des français
c'est lorsqu'il était à l'initiative et
non pas lorsqu'il était en réaction
lorsqu'il avait la maîtrise de l'agenda
et lorsqu'il avait la capacité de
pouvoir savoir et dire où on était
aujourd'hui où nous irions demain du
fait de son initiative et que par la
suite il avait la capacité à pouvoir
faire en sorte que il met en oeuvre les
moyens pour pouvoir y parvenir donc
s'ils donnent le sentiment dimanche
d'avoir la maîtrise de l'ensemble du
dispositif de dire précisément où nous
allons de donner une forme de sortie
précise de cette période de confinement
et puis de donner des perspectives non
seulement pardon en matière de santé
mais également en matière et économique
et social qu'il aura quand même
globalement réussi une partie de son
intervention de dimanche
intervention ailleurs c'est pas
inintéressant qui est annoncée quelques
jours préalablement et qui fait que
pendant trois quatre jours avant même
son intervention le président de la
république est au coeur du débat et sans
même parler aujourd'hui fait en sorte
qu' on est amené les uns ou des autres à
spéculer sur les raisons pour lesquelles
il peut être amené à prendre la parole
sur ce qu'il peut être amené à dire
suisse qu'il peut être amené à ne pas
dire et donc dans ce contexte là à
pouvoir occuper l'espace depuis le biais
de ses actionnaires
alors les internautes nous suivent très
nombreux d'un point de vue merci à vous
tous je vous lis un commentaire toujours
sur l'article de cars mais aussi cette
possibilité pour le président de la
république ou cette hypothèse
d'une démission un peu surprise suivi de
l'organisation d'une élection
présidentielle à laquelle évidemment il
serait candidat
cette annonce était uniquement un
exercice de communication nous dit alain
sur twitter pour faire le buzz sur son
énième intervention alors cheran c'est
l'occasion pour moi vous dire que ça
n'est pas une annonce de l'elysée à
moins évidemment que vous fassiez
allusion à l' annonce de l'intervention
de dimanche c'est à dire qu'il ya avant
nation officiel c'est à dire que
emmanuel macron va parler dimanche soir
aux français et puis il ya cette
information du figaro magazine dont je
parlais au début et puis il ya aussi ce
commentaire de jeanine sur twitter qui
nous dit emmanuel macron aime trop le
pouvoir et garder la vedette comme au
théâtre un jugement sévère
adrien matou votre point de vue est ce
que le président doit
faire un discours politique classique en
se contentant entre guillemets de tracer
une perspective comme comme l'évoqué à
l'instant jean daniel lévy ou est-ce
qu'il devrait prendre
est-ce qu'ils devraient renverser la
table alors on peut penser à des
initiatives comme une dissolution ou
l'organisation d'un référendum
la première chose à sur laquelle incité
c'est qu'il y aura probablement deux
discours puisque il y aura celui de ce
dimanche soir où à mon avis en tout cas
il a plutôt insisté sur
l'assouplissement du bon film ans
peut-être la levée de dernière mesure
qui restreignait de l'activité et a
priori il devrait y avoir un deuxième
discours qui aurait lieu entre la fin
juin et le 14 juillet qui à mon avis
sera plus susceptible en tout cas de
comporter des éléments de rupture on se
rappelle que le président avait parlé
pendant le film en deux mesures de
rupture qu'il allait prendre
après on peut toujours se méfier de de
cela parce que l'on peut se rappeler
aussi que pendant la crise du gilet
jaune
on avait beaucoup parlé de changements
profonds et puis finalement la même
politique a été à l'est est mené depuis
la fin des gelées jaune
donc à mon avis le si changement il doit
y avoir il devra plutôt s'agir d'un
changement politicien entre guillemets
peut-être un changement de premier
ministre mon brave beaucoup comptes
remplace qu'un départ philippaerts jean
yves le drian embargo de le maire mais
ça me paraît compliqué d'envisager un
renversement complet de politique que
voudrait dire renverser la table va
peut-être je sais pas changer
complètement la politique abandonné le
libéralisme
ça me paraît peu probable mais il faut
quand même se rappeler que un président
est toujours élu sur une base sociale il
est élu sur une base politique
emmanuel macron a quand même promis en
2010 est de faire ça certaines choses
qu'il a fait d'ailleurs depuis son
élection
donc je serais très surpris de le voir
renverser la table comme on dit et
j'aimerais bien voir comment justement
il va réussir à donner l'impression d'un
changement de cap
tout le temps quand même conservons les
fondamentaux qui le suit depuis 2007
puis en berne à ce sujet semble
provoquer chez vous une certaine
hilarité 6
le retour écran alors faites l'année ou
partager oui je dois reconnaître que on
a priori donc plus cinq cent mille
chômeurs depuis quelques semaines et que
donc même si les sujets évidemment nous
intéresse tous la vie politique
on est quand même à des années lumière
de ce qui est la préoccupation
principale des français
je ne vous le reproche pas à chaque
guillaume d'avoir voulu traiter ce sujet
parce qu'il est important mais il ne
correspond quand même pas à la réalité
de la vie quotidienne de nos de nos
compatriotes et cela a été dit tout à
l'heure il est évident que emmanuel
macron doit essayer de montrer une
certaine maîtrise ont montré une
certaine maîtrise après les épisodes
calamiteux du confinement du grand
renfermement général et montrer une
certaine maîtrise face à une crise
économique sociale et peut-être même
psychologique qui va être immense ça va
être assez compliqué et donc par
conséquent on peut penser effectivement
je dirais les manoeuvres politiciennes
serviront à compenser le manque je
dirais de maîtrise de la situation
économique et sociale
alors ça a été évoqué un parent par les
interventions précédentes il ya
plusieurs possibilités et vous même vous
en avez évoqué une le référendum si on
les prend toutes ses possibilités pour
les inventorier remaniement ministériel
c'est assez probable tout le monde le
dit mais ça serait assez logique
qu'après effectivement et bien le le
codi de la crise sanitaire
et bien il y ait une réorganisation du
gouvernement et on peut même penser que
certains le premier ministre en
particulier aurait intérêt à se mettre
au vert dans sa mairie du havre qu a
vraisemblablement reconquérir pour
devenir d'une certaine manière
disponible si jamais emmanuel macron ne
pouvait pas ou ne voulaient pas se
représenter en 2022 donc remaniement
ministériel
ça paraît assez probable dissolution
c'est quand même le risque généré de se
retrouver sans une majorité pleine et
entière
quand un président
on vient d'être élue il ya ce qu'on
appelle le phénomène majoritaire il a
une majorité parlementaire en cours de
mandat c'est peut-être quand même un peu
plus compliqué pour lui
sauf à ce qu'il veuille et ça ça
pourrait être d'une certaine manière
machiavélique essayé je dirais de faire
une majorité de plus grande coalition
encore essayé de me mouiller si vous me
permettez l'expression
d'autres partis politiques d'autres
courants pour les faire gouverner et
pour effectivement comme mitterrand en
81 8 tout comme et bien apparaître comme
n'ayant pas été véritablement
responsable de la politique menée les
deux dernières années de son mandat
troisième possibilité ça c'est les
informations sorties dans le figaro
magazine c'est la démission
on peut apparaître on peut la croire
délirante elle peut apparaître délirante
cette information je la crois assez
crédible je n'ai aucun élément pour dire
si véritablement cela va se faire mais
en tout cas ça n'est pas aussi fou que
cela puisse apparaître parce que
évidemment emmanuel macron prendrait la
de vitesse toute la classe politique
tous ceux qui essayent d'organiser à
droite une candidature d'union et bien
serait ce ver et couper l'herbe sous le
pied et par conséquent le vrai danger
pour emmanuel macron ça serait d'être de
ne pas être au second tour s'il est au
second tour là sa situation centrale sur
le spectre politique lui assure ce
qu'ils n'ont une victoire éclatante du
moins véritablement le fait la
probabilité d'être réélu et donc par
conséquent une démission pour apparaître
je dirais comme étant adoubé par le
peuple violet la pratique plébiscitaire
des élections de de gaulle
ça serait assez à ses fins ou assez
pervers comme on veut quant au
référendum alors s'agit en revanche de
n'y aura pas du tout parce que
évidemment dans un référendum
contrairement à la présidentielle ceux
qui sont contre l'exécutif se réunissent
dans les urnes c'est à dire que les noms
un de 2005 on sait bien qu'il y avait
des noms
mais les noms en 2005 et bien se sont
additionnés quoi être rejetée voilà se
sont coalisés alors alors ce n'est pas
possible
mais alors le nouveau monde est plein de
surprises parce que figurez-vous que
pour exclure a priori la dissolution et
le référendum est bien se retrouvent sur
la même ligne guillaume bernard et
devinez qui alain minc
on sait ce qu'il ne faut pas faire c'est
à dire une dissolution ou un référendum
donc après il reste le changement de
gouvernement c'est tout et où sinon
disons des signes politiques lourds et
en particulier un signe sur la
décentralisation la décentralisation
n'est plus un choix idéologique c'est
une nécessité de survie
christophe devaux que je vous livre ce
commentaire d'un internaute s'est dit ce
qui qui nous suivent sur youtube et qui
nous dit avant de renverser la table il
faut que macron retourne dans les
cuisines
il y a du boulot à la plonge et en fait
c'est intéressant parce que ça revient à
ce que disait guillaume bernard c'est
d'ailleurs peut-être un décalage entre
ce que nous observateurs nous attendons
c'est à dire une initiative politique
voire peut-être politicienne et puis les
attentes des français qui sont tout
simplement de savoir dans quel état on
va sortir de cette crise est ce que le
chômage va beaucoup monté et comment
éviter une crise sociale grave avec
beaucoup de chômage ben écoutez aussi
réagir non seulement à ce commentaire
mais aussi à ce que vient de dire à ce
que vient de dire si je veux dire à la
main après les très juste remarques de
l'éco participants moi je suis beaucoup
plus vieux qu'à la manip parce que je
suis historien et donc il dit que chirac
que nous a montrée l'erreur à la fois
d'un référendum il y une dissolution et
ensuite il nous parle de la
décentralisation comme solution
curieusement ça me rappelle qu'en avril
69 à certains chefs d'état avaient tenté
un référendum si la décentralisation
ça n'a pas été vraiment un succès
flagrant délire le thème de la
décentralisation n'est peut-être pas le
thème je suis sûr que le président
abordera mais c'est peut-être pas ce qui
va casser la baraque
dit guillaume renverser la table
moi je préfère vous raconter une
histoire parce que elle me paraît comme
on dit toute ressemblance avec des
événements et des personnages actuels
est écarté mais elle me paraît tout
assez instructive
d'autant que vous n'avez pas parlé
d'autres circonstances du contexte qui
sont quand même la colère policière et
l'incertitude politique qui porte
notamment sur le ministre de l'intérieur
là je voulais vous parler d'un homme qui
s'appelait rami bureau d'ordre coup je
sais pas si vous connaissez c'était un
condottiere est d'origine espagnole qui
était au service de césar borgia il
ramena la paix dans la romagne prix
d'une répression féroce qui finit par à
force de terroriser les habitants
provoqué un certain mécontentement non
seulement contre le gouverneur amiraux
mai contre le prince césar ce qui devait
arriver arriva le prince de masuku de
justice qui arrêtent et ramiro d'orco la
mena ou bio le découpage en quartiers et
laissa son corps en morceaux près du
couteau et du bio pour l'instruction du
peuple je vous laisse réfléchir
merci un moment peut-être encore jean
daniel lévy sur cette initiative qui
pourraient être prises en matière de
décentralisation taper un sujet qui
tourne on entend des ministres qui font
des déclarations of sur ce sujet alors
c'est vrai que on va dire que
globalement pour aller vite les maires
sont plutôt semblé ont plutôt semblé par
doit être plus convaincant que l'état
dans la gestion de la crise mais est ce
que c'est ça que les français attendent
un nouvel un nouvel élan dans la
décentralisation
ils attendent un peu des deux parce
qu'ils sont français et qui sont souvent
tendance à demander deux dimensions qui
parfois peuvent apparaître comme étant
relativement contradictoires
ils ont reconnu en général au maire la
capacité à pouvoir être hawks imité avec
les habitants à pouvoir être
relativement réactif et à pouvoir
chercher au mieux à trouver des
solutions que ce soit en matière de
masquer ce que sera en matière de
prévention relatives à la santé ou voir
même en termes d'organisation de retour
à l'école et dans un même élan
comme on est un pays qui est à une
vieille tradition républicaine est bien
une tradition d'égalité à une vieille
tradition malgré tout on fait jacobine
et où on voit bien que le premier type
de regard qui est porté en france n'est
pas forcément à l'égard de l'élu local
mais les gars de l'élu national que si
jamais doit y avoir décentralisation il
ya toujours latente de cette notion en
fait sous jacente de d'égalité
traitement de capacité de l'état à
pouvoir fournir un certain nombre de
moyens ou à septembre dead à l'égard de
l'ensemble du dispositif ce qui est
assez flagrant quand on regarde de la
paillote ya eu une forme de rupture
d'organisation territoriale au cours de
l'appel passé et où pour la première
fois le confinement n'a pas été
orchestré la même manière sur la
totalité du territoire en tout cas en
métropole et qu'on a pu voir des
départements ou des régions qui avaient
des couleurs différentes rouge orange ou
verte mais que dans un même élan qui
décide et c'était toujours le pouvoir
politique central
n'a jamais été à la discrétion soit des
présidents de conseils départementaux
soit la discrétion des présidents des
conseils régionaux soit même à l'égard
des mères ou des présidents des
structures intercommunales dont il ya eu
effectivement une politique territoriale
qui a été diverse et qui n'a pas été
tout à fait uniforme sur la totalité du
pays mais qui dans un même élan
s'inspirait toujours dans le même
registre avec un pouvoir politique
nationale qui était fort et qui
globalement décider de la manière dont
ça se passait sur sur le territoire on
voit bien d'ailleurs quand vous regardez
la participation électorale et je crois
pas des dernières élections que même
dans le cadre d'élections classique
c'est-à-dire hors périodes de covin que
la participation électorale reste malgré
tout encore plus importante à l'égard de
l'élection présidentielle qu'à l'égard
des élections municipales quand bien
même les maires seraient les élus les
plus appréciés la part des françaises et
des français
on sera plus dans quinze jours puisque à
la fin du mois s'organise le second tour
de l'élection municipale
nous terminons cette séquence si vous le
voulez bien avec de classiques d'abord
le sondage qui n'en est pas un
d'ailleurs mais en tout cas les
réactions des internautes nous avons
posé la question sur twitter croyez vous
à l'idée d'une démission surprise des
manuels macron en vue d'une
présidentielle anticipée et bien vous
êtes une grande majorité 84% à ne pas y
croire
et puis il n'y a pas d'émission point de
vue sans bien sûr celui de babineau mais
oui on est ravi de fêter le retour de
babineau notre internaute attentif qui
commente toujours nos interventions
macro on nous dit babineau doit avoir un
discours unificateur
la société est de plus en plus divisés
il doit clarifier son nouveau cap
politique
nous changeons de sujet si vous le
voulez bien je le disais les sujets de
disques